نبدا بتطورات في السودان مع اكمال المعارك
شهرها الثاني فقد افاد مصدر طبي بوقوع عدد
من القتلى والجرحى جراء قصف استهدف منطقه
حي النهضه بضاحيه الانقاذ جنوبي الخرطوم
ووصلت الطائرات الحربيه والاستطلاعيه
تحليقها في سماء مدن العاصمه فضلا عن سماع
اصوات مضادات ارضيه في جنوب ام درمان ووسط
الخرطبات نتابع الجديد من الخرطوم مع مدير
مكتب الجزيره
المسلمي الكباشي المسلم ما اخر تطورات
لديك
نعم مريم بالرغم من ان اليوم بدا
هادئا بحذر ولكن منذ الظهيره بدانا نسمع
اصوات ودوي مدفعيات بعيده في مواقع مختلفه
من العاصمه في مدنها الثلاث الخرطوم
والخرطوم بحري واندرمان وقبل حوالي ساعه
غار جويه على منطقه
الثوره بالوادي وخاصه
محليه الثوره بالقرب من كليه التربيه
جامعه الخرطوم كانت هنالك غاره جويه
استهدفت موقعا للدعم السريع وسمعنا زخات
من المضادات الارضيه تنطلق من هذه المنطقه
ومن المناطق شرقي ولا تزال من قبل قبل
قليل نسمع دليل هذه الانفجارات هذا في
الخرطوم ولكن
[موسيقى]
التطور المهمه اليوم ان
السلاح الجو السوداني قد ضرب في مواقع
كثيره للدعم السريع حول مدينه الاوبيض
غربها وجنوبها وشرقها وشمالها والدعم
السريع قوات الدعم السريع كانت تحاصر هذه
المدينه من هذه الجهات منذ اندلاع هذه
الحرب وكانت
تندفع فيها هجمات على المدينه وتصد هذه
الهجمات من الجيش داخل المدينه ولكن اليوم
المره الاولى التي يتعامل معها سلاح الجو
السوداني التابع للجيش السوداني
هذا في ان يبيض الغرب الاوسط للسودان ولكن
المعارك المسكوت عنها او ربما نقول
المعارك المعتمل التي لا يسلط عليها ضوء
اعلامي هي ما يحدث في دارفور وخاصه في
مدينه الجنينه عاصمه غرب دارفور هذه مدينه
مستباحه هذه مدينه مدينه اشباح خرج منها
الجميع
وخاصه منظمات الانسانيه
انهارت مرافق الخدمه العامه المياه
والكهرباء وانهارت مرافق الاتصالات في هذه
المدينه والموت هناك والقتل على الهويه
وتحاصر من جانباتها الاربع وانتقل انتقلت
الموت ايضا والقتل من هذه المدينه الى
جوارها في مستري وفي هبيله وفي مول هذه
مدن قريبه منها الان ايضا منذ الامس تدور
فيها معارك كذلك المعارك تدور في نيالا في
في جنوب دارفور والحال ليس لا يختلف كثيرا
في في وسط دارفور وهذا هذه الاوضاع الاخطر
التي تجري في غرب ووسط دارفور اقليم
دارفور الان اقليم
كارثي يواجه كوارث في صمت من المجتمع
الاقليمي والمجتمع الدولي نعمل مسلم
الكباشي مديره مكتب الجزيره كنت معنا من
الخرطوم شكرا جزيلا لك